it's hard times
it's a bit of odd times mostly elderly
sometimes frail and almost always
vulnerable
but here at the grange crescent care
home
they feel protected
this existence though
is now under threat
what's the increase
uh 11 times the energy crisis is
impacting the care sector with
potentially devastating consequences we
currently pay about 90 000 pounds a year
for fuel across all of our nine homes
we've been quoted
1.161 million extra
it just doesn't work that is just
not a realistic figure that we can
afford the worst case scenario we close
that is the absolute worst case scenario
and i love to see that smile on your
face this cost of living crisis means
carers like june being forced to think
about changing their jobs somebody has
to do it somebody has to care for the
residents somebody has to care they
become like your family
i care about what happens to the
residents here i can go and find a work
somewhere else but i don't want to and i
don't think i should have to just give
us enough that we can live and we can
pay our bills and we can heat our houses
and eat food i don't think that's too
much to ask for
the cost for everything is soaring
food
toiletries all essentials
the care home sector has barely
recovered from the pandemic
and now it faces another equally
daunting crisis
for the energy company this is just
another business that will struggle to
pay its bills but for the residents here
this is more than just a business
this is their home
carol says she's lucky she has family
but
a lot of people here haven't got family
anywhere near so
for it to close down would be devastated
so
i don't like the idea of that at all
the staff and residents here have a
desperate plea to the government
please help us
before it's too late
ashish joshi sky news in sheffield